Hello and welcome to this short video which is an example of the touch stimulus in action.
So here I am back in the engine and I've just moved on to example three's touch stimulus.
Now the touch stimulus is another example of something that uses the report function
in order to function. So if I was to run this now and see that I have my character
now the point that I'd bang into one of the players here registers it and they will chase after me.
So let's have a look at the state tree state tree is relatively straightforward much like
the other ones we have two main states that's either chasing or wandering about
and what makes this transition between them is a variable on the ALA player which is
registering if it has been touched. So we can see the the evaluator is communicating
that variable. If I open up the AI touch there's only a little bit of code on here.
First one is we're still using the AI perception updated but we are checking for the
AI sense touch and if it is the player we register it as touched and send it to the player.
The other element that's important is we're using the event hit in order to report the touch event
and we're carrying across the hit location and the other actor as the other vector. Very
straightforward but just gives you another example of how you go about using these report
touch events. Now if we were to look under the AI perception you'll see that we have a few other
settings that we haven't actually touched on in this. Now we've looked at the hearing,
sight and touch but there's a more advanced if you wanted to go into them we have the team
AI settings. This allows you to react when you come across pawns which are registered in either
the opposing team or your own team. It's still a C++ primarily. We also have the prediction
sense config. What this allows us to do is rather than returning a place that the character
is we can look at the speed that they are moving and predict where it will be in a set
amount of time and then return that as the result meaning that you can send your character
to walk to where the character will be rather than where the character is at that time
meaning it's got a lot more sensible pathfinder. And the damage sense config functions in a very
similar way to the touch config. Well that brings us to the end of our video on touch stimulus.
In the next video we are going to be looking at the actor component stimuli source.